so there's this Supreme Court case going
on involving that Colorado cake baker
who a few years ago refused to bake a
gay or I believe it might have been a
lesbian cake it was a gay cake okay
I mean obviously I'm kidding by the way
when I call it a gay cake or a lesbian
cake but I'm I'm sort of being satirical
and playing into the absurdity of the
entire story anyway Colorado Baker
refuses to bake a gay wedding cake and
now this is being heard by the Supreme
Court now this topic came up in a recent
Sarah Huckabee Sanders White House press
briefing of course Trump's press
secretary Sarah Huckabee Sanders speaks
for the president represents the
president's views on a variety of
different issues she was asked does
Donald Trump believe it's okay
for businesses to hang signs that say we
do not serve gay people and she said
that yes as far as the president is
concerned that type of sign no gays
served here would be included under
religious freedom as something that
businesses should be allowed to do
here's a clip from Sarah Huckabee
Sanders the lawyer for the Solicitor
General's Office for the administration
said today in court in the Supreme Court
that it would be legal it would be
possible for a Baker to put a sign in
his window saying well we don't bake
cakes for gay weddings does the
president agree that that would be okay
the president certainly supports
religious liberty and that's something
that he talked about during the campaign
it's upheld since taking office I
believe that would include I believe
that would include that meaning I
believe that that religious liberty
would include hanging a sign in your
business that says no gays allowed by
supporting that Donald Trump supports
something that is actually not that rare
on the right the idea that there are
multiple classes of people and that it's
okay to say hey this is a class of
people that is just not allowed in my
business and think about the obscene
nature of the Trump agenda taken at
large and that of the supporters of his
who absolutely love this position from
Sarah Huckabee Sanders and from Trump
more than a dozen women accuse Donald
Trump of sexual assault even a
thirteen-year-old
girl says Donald Trump raped me when I
was 13 they elect him president six or
more women I can't even keep track of
the number at this point accuse
Republican Senate candidate Roy Moore of
sexually assaulting them and Donald
Trump endorses the guy and his
supporters say yes vote for Roy Moore
someone wants a gay wedding cake and
says that being denied one is
discrimination now all of a sudden we've
gone too far and signs saying we don't
serve gays are okay and the key issue is
that in states where sexual orientation
is a protected class like religion like
race we don't serve gays sign is legally
the same as a we don't serve Christian
sign or a we don't serve blacks sign
legally speaking right and I get it some
people on the right will say no no David
it's totally different because you
choose to be gay but you are born black
and that's a silly argument in two ways
number one it's silly because you choose
your religion right and number two it's
silly because if they are all protected
classes in the eyes of the law there is
no difference but that's the problem
these people don't care about the law if
the law coincides with their worldview
then they point to the law as a defense
of their worldview when the lock
conflicts with their desires they say
the law is a problem it's impinging on
my religious freedom and it must be
changed or at minimum we should be
allowed to ignore the law based on our
so called sincerely held religious
beliefs and in fact there's an example
of this as applied to race Mormons
used to believe that black people were
actually inferior Mormons did not allow
black people to hold I don't even
remember what positions it is but
certain positions within the Mormon
Church would that religious belief have
made a no blacks allowed sign at a
Mormon owned business acceptable because
hey after all it's their sincerely held
religious beliefs in the eyes of the law
I think the answer is of course that
would not have been allowed and there
are people Pat who emailed me saying
David I actually don't care about this
because when I see a sign like that I'll
know not to give my business too
store that's totally fine right I get it
if you see a sign that says no gays
allowed and you disagree with that then
you say I'm not gonna do business I'm an
effectively boycott that business that's
fine but that doesn't change the
legality of this issue right I mean what
if there's not another bakery in your
town and you have to travel super far to
get your cake or what if it's something
that's not as frivolous as a cake and
it's an essential service we are going
way way way backwards here with this and
after a few steps forward on the LGBT
rights issue over the last several years
certainly with the Supreme Court
decision saying you can't ban same-sex
marriage in any state at the state level
we still have multiple states a couple
dozen states where you can be fired
roughly a couple dozen you can still be
fired for your perceived or actual
sexual orientation and this as the
official position of the presidency
right the official position of the
presidency is that there is no problem
with a no gays allowed sign in a
business we're going backwards
yeah and Trump had the audacity to wave
an LGBT flag now he wants the ban
transgender individuals from serving in
the military this now I mean that's just
absurd and when we heard remember that
both Hillary and Trump neither one of
them was going to go after LGBT rights
there were people saying there's really
no difference between Trump and Hillary
on LGBT rights oh wow how much of a
difference we are seeing right now send
me your thoughts I'm on Twitter at D
Pakman the show is on Twitter at David
Pakman show tremendous program coming up
for you today